I really enjoy these past seven days if  you like seven days continue to send in  the years  I'd be bigger why every guy that comes  in here to know there's a big X across  he like she's taken does never push my  boundaries and being like and in the  real world bid  especially after something like this  show we're both gonna be pushed that way  because that's that's how it is I kind  of wish you were four days before I got  here so I could walk anybody that's when  I don't know how I can you just asked me  to be your girlfriend now you're telling  me that you think I should go on dates  with other people so that I miss you  well I don't what  thank you for the sentence  they'd like 20 minutes like cocktail  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]